bonjour pascal crespin
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france on a
entendu beaucoup de déclarations hier
sur cette propagation rapide du variant
omicron qui pourrait être dominant en
europe après les fêtes quatre mille
personnes également qui pourraient se
retrouver en soins intensifs dans les
hôpitaux français est ce que il faut
s'alarmer de cette propagation du
variant omicron
alors salaire mais je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet d'inquiétude on est encore au
début de set cette vague de variants
omicron on doit déjà gérer la vague de
variants delta les les 4000 personnes en
réanimation à la fin de l'année sont
essentiellement des personnes touchées
par le werder delta et donc c'est ça
aussi la la complexité de la situation
nous avons de deux épidémies en une une
épidémie de l'art delta et une épidémie
de variole omicron à l'heure actuelle
sur le variant au micro on sait
encore relativement peu de choses on
s'est suffisamment pour être inquiet
mais mais il ya encore beaucoup
d'inconnues
le gouvernement français annonce à
nouveau conseil de défense demain at il
pris les mesures nécessaires selon vous
il se réunit demain en urgence pour en
prendre d'autres lesquels faudrait-il
prendre
alors vu david de la vague de 20,1 delta
a pris harry a priori nous arrivons un
plateau donc nous sommes en mesure à
l'heure actuelle de contrôler cette
vague et nous espérons donc quelle qu
elle commence sa descente dans les jours
à venir donc s'il n'y avait que le
variant delta effectivement bon les
mesures ce soit la vaccination la
vigilance des français en général
apparaissent comme suffisantes
malheureusement il y à 7
nouvel arrivé du werder mikron qui se
propage comme ça a été dit très
rapidement en europe à des avec une
célérité encore jamais vu pour un
variant de sorts sco b 2 et et là
effectivement la situation peut changer
les ans l'enjeu ça va être de d'essayer
de faire en sorte qu'un maximum de
personnes reçoivent sa troisième dose
mais le plus rapidement possible parce
que ça va permettre d'atténuer cette
vague de mikron
soient prises on a entendu qu'il valait
même pas attendre les 5 à 7 mois
préconisé par le gouvernement
effectivement c'est un moyen d'augmenter
en fait le la population éligible à
cette troisième dose que l'on voit dans
les dents les études qui ont été faites
c'est que alors après deux doses on
garde une certaine efficacité de leurs
de 70% contre les formes graves mais on
a très peu de protection contre contre
l'infection est donc donc on peut être
affectée et transmettre ce variant c'est
beaucoup moins le cas après cette
troisième dose parce que le niveau
d'anticorps remonte à des niveaux très
importants qui sont suffisamment
important pour être efficace contre ce
variant donc effectivement
abaissé à 3 mois l'écart entre la
deuxième dose est la troisième dose
serait un moyen de vacciner le plus
rapidement une plus grande partie de la
population et y compris les personnes
jeunes en fait don de 18 ans et plus
alors pour le pour les enfants
[Musique]
pour les enfants éventuellement
s'ils ont ils ont plus de 12 ans mais en
tout cas sur les personnes jeunes ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'il parte ils ont
beaucoup d'activité et beaucoup de
contacts ils font partie du moteur de
l'épidémie et donc les vaccinés avec
cette troisième dose qui est très
efficace doucement contre l'infection et
donc contre la transmission eh bien on
va toucher
les rouages de la mécanique épidémique
de ce vernis mikron de façon beaucoup
plus efficace ça c'est ça s'est avéré
une troisième dose protège contre les
formes graves qui seraient liées aux
variants omicron c'est et on a
suffisamment de recul pour le dire
aujourd'hui
alors ce sont les études qui ont été
faites à la fois
en afrique du sud il n'y avait pas
encore suffisamment de personnes booster
donc donc ils n'ont pas pu faire ce type
d'étude mais c'est surtout des études
qui ont été faites sur la population du
royaume uni et donc l'idée première de
ne donner que que l'on a sur
l'efficacité de la troisième dose
viennent du royaume uni et semble encore
une fois assez solide après c'est
toujours la multiplication des études
qui permet de le confirmer les premiers
résultats et d'augmenter le niveau de
confiance dans ses concerts et un
passant l'a aussi entendu hier l' agence
européenne des maladies de dire que les
vaccins ne suffirait pas qu'il fallait
une action urgente une action nécessaire
de quel ordre finalement
c'est très simple donc effectivement
malheureusement aucun vaccin à l'heure
actuelle n'est efficace à 100% que ce
soit contre les formes comme contre
l'infection contre les formes
symptomatiques ou contre les formes
graves donc il y a toujours
malheureusement des gens qui m'aiment
vacciner même triplement vacciner ils
vont passer entre les mailles du filet
vont se retrouver dans une situation
compliquée vis-à-vis du virus et parce
que ce varions mikron se propage très
facilement les niveaux à atteindre en
terme d' immunité sons sont très
importants et en fait inatteignable
juste avec la vaccination est donc
l'autre type de mesure c'est mano c'est
malheureusement la réduction de notre
activité et la réduction des contacts
oui à arrêter de bouger finalement
puisque c'est nous qui transmettront le
le variant et non pas le variant qui se
propage tout seul vous parliez de
l'afrique du sud tout à l'heure
on sait que c'est un problème mondial on
a vu un clash fric pour l'instant
n'était pas suffisamment vacciner 70 %
de la population qui seraient vaccinés
en 2024 ça fait loin quand même hein on
a l'impression qu'on concours et qu'on
se bat contre des moulins à vent
finalement
oui alors c'est clair que c'est un c'est
un problème c'est un problème qui est
mondial qui doit être gérée au niveau de
la ms avec la collaboration des états
les plus riches du monde pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que les doses soient
disponibles à ces populations
ayant 10 à l'afrique du sud mais
l'afrique en général à une population
plus jeune l'afrique du sud par exemple
à une moyenne d'âge de 27 ans quand en
europe on est plutôt autour de 41 ans ce
qui fait que par chance pour eux le
risque de faire des formes graves et
beaucoup moins fort qu'il ne l'est dans
les pays du nord et notamment les pays
européens donc là le fardeau sanitaire
provoquée par ce parce que 8,19 va être
est déjà beaucoup plus faible et c'est
restera beaucoup plus faible que celui
qu'il peut être dans les bus dans les
pays du nord et donc ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas vaccinés ces populations
parce que encore une fois l'important
c'est de baisser la circulation du virus
pour éviter l'émergence de nouveaux
variants mais ça veut dire aussi que
c'est un facteur de complexité pour les
dirigeants de ces pays d'afrique parce
que la perception du risque lié à la
maladie est potentiellement un peu moins
forte qu'elle ne l'est en europe et on
voit toute la problématique de
l'hésitation vaccinale que l'on a en
europe et en particulier en france et
celle ci est aussi présente cette
hésitation vaccinale dans les pays
d'afrique donc il faut pas se dire non
plus que il suffit juste qu'ils aient
des doses pour qu'ils puissent
facilement vacciner toute la population
c'est toujours un peu plus compliqué que
ça le chef de l'état hier en dire que on
allait sans doute s'acheminer vers des
rappels réguliers est ça va devenir
finalement une sorte de grippe le coc
vide
alors je sais pas si c'est souhaitable
l'idéal serait d'arriver à une forme de
d'élimination mais là pour le coup je ne
sais pas si c'est possible donc ça fait
partie des scénarios qui sont qui sont
envisageables
malheureusement seul seul l'avenir nous
le dira et là ce qui est sûr c'est que
malheureusement on n'y est pas encore et
que ce variant omicron n'est pas qu'un
simple rhume justement l'afrique du sud
a montré récemment
qu'il qu'il était sévère un peu
peut-être un peu moins sévère que le vin
delta mais juste de l'ordre de 25% moins
sévère le variant delta était presque
deux fois plus sévère que le variant
alpha sy fait qu' on est encore sur des
niveaux de sévérité très important des
banques malheureusement la fin d'un
parti n'est pas encore là bas ma
question sur la grippe c'était ce qui
est fort adapté finalement le la
contenance des vaccins en fonction
justement d'aider nouveau variant est ce
qu'on pourrait anticiper les nouveaux
variants comme on le fait actuellement
pour la grippe par exemple
alors c'est possible
en fait ce qui nous permet d'anticiper
mais les virus qui circule d'un
hémisphère à l'autre c'est justement
cette déclinaison
cette circulation alternée entre
l'hémisphère nord et l'hémisphère sud et
la surveillance globale qui nous permet
de savoir de deviner un peu quels seront
les variants qui circuleront d'une
saison à l'autre malheureusement avec ce
mec ceux commis 19 le parce qu'il se
transmet beaucoup plus facilement on
arrive à avoir des épidémies que ce soit
en hiver comme en été et donc qu'on ne
peut pas vraiment bénéficié de ce
phénomène là mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que on est théoriquement capable
d'adapter les vaccins beaucoup plus
rapidement et donc on pourrait compenser
ce phénomène mais on n'a pas non plus
envie de vacciner les gens tous les
quatre matins donc je pense que une des
solutions serait plutôt de d'arrivée de
parvenir à un vaccin avec un spectre
peut-être plus large et en fait les
vaccins que l'on a parce qu'ils sont
contre le vario originel ont déjà en
fait un spectre assez large
mais encore une fois seul seul l'avenir
le dira quelle est la meilleure
stratégie merci beaucoup pascal crespin
pour ce point très complet sur la
pandémie actuellement merci à vous